legendaries and outriders are somewhat
difficult to come by but they have fun
and unique abilities so
they're absolutely worth trying to get
your hands on and luckily for you
there are ways to easily guarantee a
legendary and we're gonna talk about a
few of them in this video
just as a heads up we'll be talking
about certain side quests but will not
spoil any major story beats
so you're good if you want more guides
like this one don't forget to like and
subscribe
alright now let's get into it okay so
this one's pretty obvious but
finish the game once you've beaten all
riders you'll be rewarded with a loot
crate that has a random legendary in it
easy peasy work your way up to world
tiers 12 through 15.
world tiers add difficulty the game as
they make your enemies a higher level
but they reward you with better loot
drops
world tier 12 through 15 will give you
four legendary weapons
at the time of this recording it appears
that the four legendary weapons you
receive
are level 40. this one also requires you
to have finished the game
but one of your crewmates tiago will
sell you legendaries once you've
completed it
he has eight separate legendaries you
can acquire from him for
drop pod credits you occur drop pod
credits by completing expeditions which
is the end game content for outriders
the higher the tier of expedition the
more credits you will receive
so far it does not appear that there is
a timer on the eight pieces he sells you
thiago is a useful guy to have around as
he also sells epic gear that matches
your level
what a guy then there are specific side
quests
the list of side quests i'm about to
list will all reward you with a
guaranteed
legendary by the end of them some are
faster than others to complete but all
of them are worthwhile for those great
drops
bounty hunts for eugeo by completing all
10 bounty hunts you will receive a
random legendary weapon from him
you can see the various bounty hunts
through the map with the target icon
you can either complete these as you're
going through the areas or finish them
once you're done with a story
you can repeat the side quests and
finish all 10 bounty targets again to
get
another random legendary weapon monster
hunts for noah
dembele in the same vein as the quest
for eugeo there are 10 monsters you can
kill
during your playthrough or after you
beat the game kill those 10 monsters and
turn in the quest to noah and you'll be
rewarded with a random legendary armor
like eugeo you should be able to redo
these quest lines to receive another
random legendary armor
the historian madame bevoir has side
quests that are littered throughout the
various areas of
outriders as you may have guessed finish
all of her historian quest and she
too will also give you a random
legendary also some of the historical
items you pick up
are some fun easter eggs including a
novel called
a storm of bullets get it
because they made the developers of this
game made
okay the big iron side quest for china
and the desolate four
area requires that you salvage some
weapon parts and tech
that's laying around in the desert once
you've gained all the parts she will
grant you a legendary
reward this time you'll get to pick one
of three
weapons the three that i was able to
pick up were the aerie master legendary
shotgun
the landlubber a bolt action rifle and
grim marrow and lmg forgotten chapel
another side quest that is later in the
story requires you to touch
three different touchstones in the
canyon of the grand
obelisk this quest isn't indicated by a
marker but once you touch the first
stone your outrider will say
i wonder what this does the first one is
just outside the starting area then
you'll have to fight your way past some
monsters
to the next area for the second one the
third and final one is pass
more enemies through a gate that is part
of the story
once you've touched the last touchstone
you'll receive
the side quest fast travel your way back
to the record apc
and run up the hill back to this door
you passed by
earlier that was closed to receive a
random legendary from a chest
outrider's legacy another side quest
you'll get during your playthrough
involves investigating a secret
outrider's bunker
each part of the side quest will have
you fight through enemies and pick up
information or
keys each key will open up different
rooms in the bunker
once you open the last room in the
bunker you'll finish the quest which
will net you another random legendary
and there you have it over 10 guaranteed
legendaries you can get
in outriders once you reach the end game
of outriders you can start to try to
farm legendaries more efficiently
as you progress through the higher
difficulty expeditions
as you ramp up the difficulty you get a
higher percent drop rate for legendaries
from the drop pod at the end
and don't forget if you enjoyed this
video to hit that like and sub button
we'll see you next time outrider
you